it might seem intuitive that we can
predict tomorrow's weather pretty well
but not whether it will rain on Tuesday
three weeks from now but we didn't
always think that way about the weather
our understanding of the atmosphere and
its patterns was forever changed by the
contributions of two exceptional
pioneers MIT professors Jule Charney and
Edward Lorenz heralds of the modern era
of meteorology Charney and Lorenz each
in his own way left an indelible mark on
MIT and the world at the height of the
second world war an unprecedented demand
for weather forecasting expertise fueled
a nationwide effort to train a
generation of meteorologists among the
young recruits was UCLA graduate student
Joule Gregory Charney who had discovered
a talent for mathematics at an early age
anticipating the United States entry
into World War two and encouraged by
Caltech professor Theodore von Karman he
signed up for a course in meteorology in
1940 seeing an opportunity to excel
meanwhile on the other side of the
country at MIT an aviation cadet and
mathematics graduate named Edward Norton
Lorenz began his own training in 1942 in
the Department of meteorology course 19
marking the beginning of a lifelong
connection to the Institute when the war
ended Lorenz returned to MIT to complete
his master's degree and PhD in
meteorology after graduating in 1948 he
stayed on as a research scientist
working with the Victor Starr
the general circulation of the
atmosphere after publishing a landmark
paper on atmospheric energy cycles
called
available potential energy and the
maintenance of the general circulation
Lorenz joined the faculty in 1955 his
advisor Victor Starr had been recruited
by Henry Houghton head of mi t--'s
Department of meteorology from 1942 to
1969 during his tenure Houghton
transformed the department into a
cutting-edge research powerhouse he
founded the training program attended by
Lorenz during the war
which grew the department more than
tenfold and oversaw the development of
weather radar later in a prescient move
he nurtured mi T's growing oceanography
program with help from the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution and saw it
integrated with Atmospheric Research
Houghton's vision and guidance laid a
far-reaching foundation for scientific
advance that would shape the
meteorological world for decades to come
while Lorentz was beginning his career
in meteorological research at MIT Jewell
Charney was beginning to embark on a new
adventure of his own
following the war Charney had returned
to UCLA to complete his doctorate in
1946 his PhD thesis dynamics of long
waves in a Barrow clinic westerly
current was groundbreaking work which
established the mechanism for the
emergence and evolution of weather
systems and what sets their structure
size and growth rate this was an early
example of Charney's aptitude for
applying mathematics to understanding
physical processes and my first
experience over the next two years
working first as a research scientist at
the University of Chicago with Carl
Gustav Rossby who founded the first
meteorology program at MIT in 1928 and
then as a National Research Council
fellow studying in Oslo Charney
developed his quasi geostrophic
equations which laid the foundation for
modern dynamical meteorology and
oceanography these equations not only
allowed large-scale motions of the
atmosphere to be analyzed without being
overshadowed by noisy effects at smaller
scales they could also be integrated
forward in time to predict the weather
in 1948 Charney took up an appointment
at Princeton University's Institute for
Advanced Study to work with
mathematician John von Neumann and
future MIT meteorology professor Norman
Phillips on the earliest numerical
weather prediction models their first
calculations were run on the ENIAC
computer and published in 1950 and in
the years that followed Charney's
theoretical meteorology group
demonstrated that the quasi geostrophic
equations
were able to reproduce important aspects
of the general circulation and even
predict the formation of cyclones this
resounding success won widespread
acceptance in the Meteorological
community for numerical weather
prediction the equations also became the
theoretical foundation of modern
dynamical meteorology and oceanography
permeating every aspect of the field
[Music]
building on this momentum Charney helped
to establish the joint numerical weather
prediction unit in 1954 a collaboration
between the u.s. weather bureau Air
Force and Navy
a year later he had a hand in starting
up the general circulation research
section of the weather bureau and while
this group would eventually become
NOAA's geophysical fluid dynamics
laboratory and relocate to Princeton
Charney was already considering a move
to MIT during an interview then provost
and vice president julia Stratton asked
Charney what could be done to improve
the meteorology department having always
been impressed by Ed Lorenz then still a
research scientist
Charney replied that the first thing to
do would be to promote Lorenz and his
adviser Victor Starr he also reached out
to recruit his Princeton colleague
Norman Phillips Lorenz and Phillips were
duly offered faculty positions and
Charney likewise joined MIT to direct
the atmospheric and ocean dynamics
project in 1956
charismatic and open-minded Charney had
a knack for bringing people together he
quickly established an informal seminar
series on geophysical fluid dynamics a
tradition that would continue for 22
years
attracting experts from around New
England in the fields of meteorology
oceanography geophysics and applied
mathematics during his 25 years at MIT
Charney mentored countless students and
made profound lasting impacts on the
field through groundbreaking research on
such diverse topics as the stability of
atmospheric and oceanic flows the
formation and evolution of weather
systems and hurricanes oceanic boundary
currents how large-scale planetary waves
extend up into the stratosphere the
formation of deserts and how westerly
winds can flip between banded and wavy
patterns he also continued to play a
role in the establishment of critical
weather-related initiatives including
the global atmospheric research program
an observational effort improving
numerical weather prediction one of
Charney's last contributions was a
pioneering study conducted for the
National Academy of Sciences the 1979
Charney report was one of the earliest
modern scientific assessments of global
warming he estimated that a sustained
doubling of atmospheric co2 would lead
to a surface temperature increase of
between 1.5 and 4.5 degrees centigrade a
range that has been vigorously debated
and has stood the test of time though
Charney and Lorenz shared a similar
background in mathematics and a mutual
admiration for one another the two never
worked together directly during their
time at MIT nevertheless their research
interests intersected and the
development of numerical weather
prediction facilitated by Charney's
equations carried Lorentz's research
into atmospheric dynamics forward
in 1967 he published the nature and
theory of the general circulation of the
atmosphere a treatise now considered a
classic work of scientific literature by
that time however a new exciting
research direction had begun to occupy
Lawrence's attention in 1963 after
noticing that very slightly different
initial conditions due to roundoff
errors generated by his LGP 30 computer
resulted in rapidly diverging solutions
Lorenz published a landmark article on
chaos theory the idea that nonlinear
systems such as weather are practically
unpredictable despite their
deterministic evolution the Lorenz
system three differential equations that
relate to the motions of a fluid layer
warmed from below and cooled from above
is one of the fundamental systems
studied in chaos theory these simple
equations revealed startling behavior
which led Lorenz to an important insight
though the chaotic solutions never
repeat they nevertheless tend to look
very similar even when starting from a
range of initial conditions run many
times the solutions trace out a
previously unknown mathematical object
that Lorenz termed a strange attractor
this fractal set of solutions introduced
new tools to analyze nonlinear chaotic
systems helping to answer questions like
why some weather pattern geometries are
common while others seem never to occur
continuing his study of predictability
Lorenz demonstrated in 1969 that the
nonlinear interaction among motions of
many different scales could lead to loss
of predictability even when the model is
perfect and the initial errors are
vanishingly small
[Music]
I think this is what we should have
expected all the time but I never heard
this theory was popularized as the
butterfly effect the idea that small
changes can have large consequences
lorenza's discovery not only
revolutionized to the understanding of
fluid turbulence and weather but also
led to advances in mathematics the
natural sciences and engineering Lorenz
was a vital member of MIT for over 60
years serving as the head of meteorology
from 1977 to 1981 much-beloved as an
instructor and mentor he was repeatedly
honored as best teacher of the year by
MIT graduate students and he continued
to conduct research and give lectures
well after becoming a professor emeritus
in 1987 he passed away on April 16th
2008 and three years later MIT created
the Lorenz Center in his honor dedicated
to furthering the basic understanding of
climate science by comparison Jewell
Charney's tenure at MIT was relatively
brief after a fierce battle with cancer
he died on June 16th 1981 just two years
after publishing his pioneering report
on the connection between carbon dioxide
and climate even so his impact on MIT
and around the world stands
shoulder-to-shoulder with out at his
colleague and friend Ed Lorenz born 100
years ago
both men fundamentally reshaped the
science of meteorology during their
lifetimes
Charney saw the dawn of numerical
weather prediction and its widespread
influence on nearly every aspect of
atmospheric and oceanographic research
Lorenz shifted our basic conception of
weather and climate from deterministic
phenomena to chaos and this insight
suggested new ways to examine nonlinear
chaotic systems an impact that spread
outward from meteorology to transform a
host of other disciplines but perhaps
their most enduring legacy is the
community of people trained taught and
inspired by Joule Charney and Edler
well I discovered after moving to MIT
was that I what I did enjoy mostly was
working or intensive legal aggressions
on thesis search problems because I find
that my own work is greatly enhanced and
positive times much more enjoyable when
I can today the study of atmospheric
science continues at MIT in the wider
context of eats the Department of Earth
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences
formed in 1983 from the merger of
meteorology and Earth Sciences now 100
years later the program in atmospheres
oceans and climate within eeap's
celebrates and honors the lives of
Charney and Lorenz as their students and
their students students continue to walk
in their footsteps exploring the myriad
reverberations of the work they set in
motion
[Music]
you